I know normally you see this show on a
white table but today we're going to be
using Lord's wood a beautiful textured
wood hey it's Scott Disick and I'm going
undercover on the internet and it is
actually me Cora
he's Cora what a Scott Disick do for a
living
a lot of people don't realize that I
guess I do get paid to be on national
television I don't know last time I
checked that is a living but at the same
time I also have always done business
and always have invested my money wisely
and I've always constantly taken every
dollar I've made and turned it into more
money and it's been pretty good so
there's how I make a living
blast that what are some of the Scott
Disick's major accomplishments think the
biggest accomplishments I have are three
things Penelope Mason and rain and
that's it
submit write it seriously
it's actually me do you think Scott
Disick uses propecia honestly any time I
see a picture of him I'm like wow you
haven't lost a single strand of hair
literally perfect hair perfect hairline
thank you no I don't use any hair loss
products my hair is just flowing in the
wind and it always will be
Twitter
[Music]
Haley Barrett Scott what's your tanning
secret I don't know that there's a
secret to tanning other than you just
lay when the Sun is out for as long as
possible the end how did you become a
lord I don't want to become one myself I
totally understand where you're coming
from and it's definitely not an easy
road to become a lord you can simply go
Bing Linden buy a piece of land but you
got to get night it there's a lot of
things to get involved in so I wouldn't
suggest it to everyone but if you have
the time on your hands by all means get
knighted Musti Scott would you wear
flip-flops with jeans no I don't think
so
Juliana Barra how did you become a
successful entrepreneur learning
business it was always something that I
had in my blood and over the years I
just realized what kind of things could
create and become more valuable with my
touch and with in real estate and
clothing and things of that nature
I was able to generate more and more
income off of those things posted
Kristin what is your obsession with
suits don't get me wrong I love them but
how did you get obsessed with them so as
you know I don't really dress nearly as
a formal as I used to and I think my
obsession with suits was back in the day
was that nobody really wore them and
then I started getting more interested
in the layers of the ties and the colors
and the cufflinks and the shirts and the
shoes and it just became a hobby and
then I realized one day how
uncomfortable it was now I kind of not
that obsessed with suits send it when's
the last time you pranked as Todd
kraines
I'm pound bored need to know now so most
of my pranks are one-offs but I don't
think the Todd kraines prank has been
for a couple of years but that was a
good one and I should bring that one
back so look out for that Instagram
for real it's actually me daniela
Shapira you are a dope king what are the
five essentials you own that you just
can't live without cell phone car
sunglasses phone charger and a credit
card that doesn't sound great enter oh
great
even more Twitter Dan Espinoza man how
did you get to be such a badass high
five
so a little bit of your chill rubs off
on me dude I don't know that that's a
question but thank you and if I ever see
you I will rub one off on you that's on
the internet now rum
I wonder what's got Disick's skincare
routine it's like Oh ROM thanks for
asking I start with an apricot scrub and
then no I'm just kidding
so really my routine is just being as
clean as possible I shower twice a day
once in the morning once at night I
don't feel like I could get into bed
being dirty from the day and skincare
wise
I really just clean and moisturize
I am DB nicknamed Lord Disick LD Scotty
so Scotty LD maybe more so just lord the
lord of the manor the lord of the night
I think that's about it more Twitter M
eg hey Scott can you describe your ideal
night out in Vegas
well those priorities have changed a
long time ago my night in Vegas is a lot
different than my night in Vegas now my
ideal night in Vegas probably now would
be with all my kids and going to a fun
restaurant fun show and staying at a
nice hotel and probably getting up early
and getting back home to LA and entering
well that was fun thank you so much for
all the questions and I will see you
later
[Music]